you take what did you say a a liberal in
san francisco
or a freaking redneck in montana and you
pull them into a room and say
do you want to be able to take care of
your family what are they going to say
they're going to say yes do you want to
be able to handle yourself in a pressure
situation they're going to say yes
do you want to be able to take care of
yourself they're going to say yes so
there's an alignment
that's that's inherent in what you're
teaching
that absolutely will bring people
together but it'll make them better not
just because they're able to survive
it'll it'll teach them a way of thinking
yeah that will progress them
in every aspect of their life and that's
why i think
it's even more powerful than what you're
saying because i could take
some uh company executives and send them
to one of your courses
and and yes it's a cool benefit that
they're gonna learn
about survival just like i run a program
where we take our guy we take
civilians we teach them how to do a room
clearance we teach them how to move
between buildings right
this is a one this is a this is a 45
minute session right
how to clear a room and how to move from
building to building in a group that's
what we teach them
then we say okay here's your mission and
we start giving them missions now
what do they learn about clearing
buildings doesn't matter it doesn't
matter at all
but what do they learn about leadership
what do they learn about thinking under
pressure
what do they learn about how to get
people to move in the right direction
what do they learn about being able to
detach and take a step back
and not get caught up in the fire fight
we use later attack
not get caught up in their laser gun and
and freaking out about that
so we take people and put them through
this tactical training
not so that they can become great
tacticians but
so that they can lead better so what
you're doing hey listen it's great you
put people through
some training that they learn survival
skills
but to me an even even
higher up of the hierarchy of of
benefits
is that they learn a way of thinking
that's going to benefit them in every
aspect of life
i think that's badass yeah yeah i
appreciate it the
the lessons learned that we found is
exactly that that
most often people aren't exposed
they they have limited exposure so when
they have the opportunity to do
something like
you know a five-day uh experience like
we have you know we do corporate
training we do
um we've done it i've consulted for
oracle and some other companies
it's not about like you said the
technical experience
the bottom line is they're not going to
learn enough reps to build that
technical expertise
unless that's on their own but the life
lessons they learn
and taking it back and processing stress
like you said
is so important and valuable i think
what's happening with
this introduction of technology in our
lives
is it's limiting our ability to be
exposed
so um one of the advices that i give for
people
who are like how do i change my mindset
you know a lot of people say mindset
mindset mindset what the hell does that
mean in in our field of expertise it has
to do with resilience
your ability to bounce back your ability
once suppressed to bounce back and to be
stronger
to thrive instead of just survive and
get by so
when we expose people to new challenges
it doesn't have to be extreme you could
just i mean we have extreme versions of
this we do seer school
we have a civilian serious school which
is fun to run but those guys
will come back from that experience from
a five-day seer experience survival
escape resist evade
and they'll go this is the most
impactful thing i've ever done in my
life
and i'm like really and like okay
let me reflect on my impactful
experiences oh yeah ranger school
when i was in ranger school and i'm
exposed and i'm
i'm vulnerable it's impactful because
it's something different and we
understand this obviously about
even single-celled organisms if you're
exposed to trauma
that is the first stage in growth
because no growth takes place without
exposure to trauma
and so whatever that form factor is
getting pummeled on the mats and jiu
jitsu
you are learning as you go you're
breaking to build
and so uh what's fascinating about this
whole movement that i
that i think is preparedness is that
it's positive
there's not a lot of negative things
that take place
in preparing people to be prepared for
that worst case scenario
you see a lot of positive impacts on
community with law enforcement
with relationships uh with people's
understanding
and for me um getting
getting all this collective of
information and making sense of it
and being able to clearly disseminate
that is the biggest challenge
but it's the funnest thing about the
business i mean the lms for example of
of creating this idea that you could
learn online
and you could learn about these
life-saving things the naysayers came
out and said
why would you teach somebody how to
apply a tourniquet online like
don't you think that's kind of like a
it's high in liability and it's
neglectful
i'm like dude you could build a a rocket
ship
inside of your garage off a youtube
video so i could think i think i could
teach somebody how to stop the bleed
with a technical
tourniquet applied to their body to help
them survive
and so i i'm fascinated by it's it's my
passion obviously but um
i think you're right i think especially
when it comes to leadership
uh there's a breakdown in our in our
societies with
guys not willing to get off the bench
and do anything for themselves
i was doing a podcast with pete blaber
he was a former
uh cad commander uh wrote the mission
the man and me and work uh just wrote
part two of that which is the common
sense way
and one of the things he talks about is
this idea of collaboration
and when you collaborate with somebody
when you have communication
and you have reciprocation then you you
create the environment of
us willing to learn from each other but
you also give people the confidence to
stand up in their own communities and do
something about it
i don't care if it's not their community
like yeah you want to run for city
council that's great
you don't and you just want to stand up
and get off your ass for your family
or even for yourself you're fat you're
sloppy
you're lazy and you can make a change
inside yourself because you
you come to that realization that's good
for me
there's no revenue generated there it
could be a podcast it could be one way
dissemination
that impact is priceless it's worth
everything in the world